morning Michelle good morning miss Polly
Maddox had the perfect job Chelsea
diamonds has chosen us to redo that
campaign I thought you two would be
perfect to head this up and the perfect
friends this place is crawling with guys
I'll keep my eye out got ahold of a
couple tickets to this I meant to call
you back I just got caught up with stuff
but wouldn't stop looking guys like that
don't really exist it's fantasy entities
people want fantasy trying to pursue
that makes people miserable for the
perfect man ever since I was a kid I've
done a bunch of hats for help sir for us
back to school and slacks true romance
is fantasy fairy tales come true she
just she was pretty wrapped up in a guy
that she just met I'm Carol Bo's mom -
fairy tale endings and grandkids she'll
discover where is everybody we confirmed
there guy cancelled both maybe perfect
isn't so perfect after all are you
trying to ruin my career no I'm trying
to help your career and true love you
look really great could be waiting right
in front of you when work and play
marvista entertainment presents your
perfect know and that's why I'm leaving
a holiday fairy tale about finding the
perfect love in the most imperfect
places
Claire coffee Ryan McPartlin Gabrielle
Denis Jeff Ward
you're amazing
you